what's going on reject nation Greg
al-baqi and Jean Humphrey here so
justice laconic our trailer is here we
got a chopper 15 more minutes before we
going oh yeah before we go into the
shadows Andrew Hayes today preacher the
day let's play the trailer are you ready
John I'm ready are you ready Greg yeah
this is your flesh yeah yeah Gordon
[Music]
I'm okay with that what this I'm cute
whoa water woman's place
[Music]
[Music]
we can die left me nothing very
interesting battle remains in mourning
after the death oh no show you said the
aged appearance would never come again
[Music]
we don't have any more time
[Music]
oh there is
nature teacher
you want to be
what could kill me
Oh
like uh computers one this is the day so
mom's biggest concerns or exploding
white oak penguins namely this is crazy
a birthing wall and I Oh Matt some ways
held back
engage allowed until this together
oh yeah about time they don't take it
from here Joyner you help I've worked at
once again with a beacon to the world
in stage two the best parts of the south
[Music]
Oh
last recognize of the song
you just have to save it
very
[Music]
oh hell yeah at the cool shot how many
of you are there
no we're super you resist oh wow they
just they really just vanish Oh food
[Laughter]
[Music]
dress part ma'am
you said you'd come no that's hope you
know too late son of B hey Supes really
thought I could see it for sure the
socks do they just keep it did John feel
it oh yeah
a rectangle I could feel it like 5 sec
yeah yeah just from ovary that was a
really cool trailer mean the more
footage we keep getting from Justice
League the better I think this movie
looks one of the things I walked away
from with this trailer was cyborg
actually that's cool this is me am i
doing black stuff and whatever go
attacking into the Batmobile and talking
to Alfred I'm like even though that's
not like a big explosive CGI seeing
doesn't needs to be they finally get a
sense for what's special about yeah
that's a set that's really really is a
cool special ability personality can I
think the cinematographer here looks
excellent the way this film is shot just
looks absolutely beautiful it looks like
IMAX cameras and I heard they shot a lot
of it with IMAX cameras the depth
perception and the clear quality looks
like IMAX shots it's shot differently
than BBS or Man of Steel Gordon looks
great that Aquaman looks freaking
awesome the ethical shall we jumped
through the building that came out out
front man that was super sweet
Steppenwolf looks amazing we don't
really get much of him in the trailer
we're getting a sense for what the
mother boxes are a little bit more I'm a
little curious to find out what's going
on with Barry Allen specifically in this
movie because you know we got Batman
established they had that penguin
reference which is pretty funny they got
Batman established and he's already had
like a lifelong of fighting criminals
and everything he's been around for a
while
yeah but then Barry Allen has a line in
here of like I've never gone down I'm
just push people around and while that's
funny it was making me go oh what point
in Flash's career is this acting I you
know has he not been fighting people has
he not been to say like saving lives so
how come Batman's life is here how
they'll hot off the origin are we yeah
with with his wife flash
I mean when we give the solo flash movie
it can be an origin tale which would
kind of be weird since the flashy like
really again origin tale or heading
grand I know it's separate but you know
already getting a flash show that's our
be covering a lot of that and I even
like that touch or at one point it sound
like I have been Steppenwolf talking for
you like no protectors you know latter
and say yeah this is always talking
about where does Green Lancer distri
mance are going to be coming out soon
and everyone's just trying to find out
more about it are they going to actually
get something going or Greenland's no
Green Lantern movie confirmed
I like how a lot of this trailer seems
to be stemming from the fact that
Superman did die and that that is a big
inspiration for why the Justice League
is assembled so they're still making
Superman a vital component and I like
how they're teasing him because it most
likely that's alfred talking a superman
at the end that's what I took that's
what I took from it and this whole
trailer a lot of it is revolving around
Superman this the music sounds like the
Man of Steel song rendition and which
sounded great all the Aquaman effects
look everything about this this looks
really awesome it's just a rock and
Sock'em good time when it will feel like
a heroic touch too it's something that
the Wonder Woman movie had not a Jeff
Jones has been involved in producing
this I imagine that this will really
have the heroic vibe of the team
assembling together I'm excited for it
yeah I mean this this is a pretty cool
trail I like I just like the touch that
they're not showing us much Superman I
like that they're kind of committing to
keeping that at least shadowy I don't
know how it's going to figure it out and
I like that fact I feel like you're a
bit more excited than I am because I'm
used to seeing cool scenes out of this
movie by now so I'm like yeah more cool
scenes alright yeah I'm going in with a
little bit of trepidation and this
didn't exactly is swage it but it did
make me excited especially seeing
Commissioner Gordon got me excited
seeing more of cyborg seeing more of
Aquaman got me excited I like the
Aquaman seems to be like a badass dude
and is having a fun time too yeah which
which might be out of character for
Aquaman coming out of the comic books
but you know like as much as Aquaman
gets attune you know people don't treat
that character very well very kind of
last character at least now in modern
pop culture
I like the Aquaman gets a chance to be a
be a again you know and I'm excited to
see all these people come together this
trailer gives me a lot of really cool
huge action set pieces and so I think
moving forward from this but
thing I would like is something else I
know this movie is going to have a lot
of cool and gigantic and probably very
spectacular action sequences VBS is full
of those kinds of things you know manis
feel a lot of the things I know that
from this world and so coming out of BBS
and washing that taste out of my mouth I
would like to something a little bit
more in the character Department from
one of these trailers just so that I can
feel more the movie the the BBS trailer
had all that action you know in it and I
feel like they're completely leading
with action on this movie so that's the
one thing that I wasn't as excited about
was just like oh cool more action I mean
that's not a fair point but I would say
to that though is this looks like a
there's a lot more set pieces than
either one of the DC films that provided
so far there's so many set pieces and
you got so many characters and the main
thing it's the traitors are giving me
what I want which is while it doesn't
look like a heavy character development
going on you still you can definitely
see these characters have a lot of
personality I'm interested to see the
dynamics of how they've changed now with
Bruce Wayne and Diana
Aquaman and Barry have a lot of
personality to them gordon seems like he
has a good personality too so when it
comes to this the major mashup movie all
I really care about is having a fun time
Rock'em Sock'em action like even when it
came to Marvel's Avengers I was like I
just want to see these characters have a
lot of fun and have some really cool
action because when it comes to the
character and story stuff while that's
important even for a film like Justice
League adda Justice League like I feel
like it will be more than just cool
action yeah it should be but I feel like
the main thing that I really just care
about is having a really fun time with
these characters yeah and don't get it
don't get me wrong like that's what I
want at the end of the day out of this I
want to walk out having had a good time
and stuff like that I just you know
especially in these trailers what I do
like about this is that we see so much
more of the world in the scope you know
we rinse a mascara we see a little bit
of Atlantis we see the more human world
like I like that the world is getting
broader now yeah I guess that's the only
thing that's missing from these trailers
for me is it's just a little bit more
seen like stuff I want know what the
scenes are going to be like the action
looks Zack Snyder epic you know and if
there's one thing Zack Snyder and I know
Joss Whedon's taken over now
those dudes are good at really well shot
action scenes and I can tell who's I'm
gonna have a lot of this yeah and like
we promised Andrew Hayes over at patreon
shadow the day to you Andrew Hayes I
give you a lot of praise when you put me
in a daze as I gaze upon the glaze of
your face flash faces flash phases see
fades I don't know
guys mr. Norton Andrew Hayes but I give
you your patron of the day shout out
here
you should be happy with that Andrew you
wanted it for Justice League hashtag
flash fit I love you okay I love I love
it Patriot a shout-out sure it's just
not that really hurt your leg all right
guys what do you think of the Justice
League trailer you excited for it I'm
sure you are you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell - John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram and check out all our
exclusive personal rewards at
patreon.com slash the real reject